MIKE: Danielle is sending us to
visit Terry and his wife Jean.
Their collection
covers everything,
but it focuses on
eye-related stuff.
FRANK: Hello!
JEAN: Hi, there.
FRANK: Jean and Terry?
MIKE: How're you doing?
JEAN: Yes.
FRANK: How're you doing?
MIKE: Man, this is
a beautiful property!
FRANK: Beautiful.
JEAN: Thank you so much.
FRANK: I see the lake
out there for fishing too.
JEAN: Oh, yeah, yeah.
That's kind of a bonus.
MIKE: Here, watch this,
I'm gonna bust these out on ya.
TERRY: Oh, there,
I've seen them before.
MIKE: She said you
were in the business.
TERRY: There you are.
MIKE: How many years
were you in?
TERRY: 40.
MIKE & FRANK: 40 years!
TERRY: As an ophthalmologist,
I'm interested in collecting
old eye-related antiques
and instruments
that were used back
in the early 1900s.
And also quackery.
MIKE: She also said that
you guys have been married
for over 50 years?
TERRY: 54.
JEAN: 54 and a half now.
MIKE: No kidding.
FRANK: That's how old I am.
TERRY: We were
high-school sweethearts.
MIKE & FRANK: No kiddin'.
TERRY: So we ended up
getting married.
Interestingly, she was 21, I was
20; we're about 5 months apart.
MIKE: Oh, really?
JEAN: [laughs]
MIKE: Can we look
around a little bit?
TERRY: Oh, absolutely.
JEAN: Sure, come in.
MIKE: Man.
TERRY: Come on in.
TERRY: We decided to downsize,
because the kids have let
us know what they want,
and there's still
a lot of stuff.
And we would like to pass it on
so someone else can enjoy it.
MIKE: Oh, my gosh,
look at those, Frank.
TERRY: What'd you find?
FRANK: This is a cool
little sign here.
It's got the spectacles
right on there.
TERRY: That is very nice.
FRANK: I mean, it's early.
Do you remember
where you got this?
TERRY: No.
FRANK: No?
Just when you were buying?
TERRY: That's probably
30, 40 years ago.
FRANK: You wanna
plug this one in?
TERRY: Yes.
FRANK: Hit it.
TERRY: There it is.
FRANK: Oh, yeah.
That's pretty.
FRANK: You know, when
the bulbs burn out,
a lot of people put
a regular 50-watt, 60-,
or 100-watt in there.
Well, that heats up,
and then makes it flake
away from the front.
FRANK: Octagon, right?
8-side?
TERRY: Right.
That particular configuration
was replaced by oval frames,
probably in the 40s.
So that dates it
probably from the 30s.
TERRY: That would be in an
optician's dispensing shop.
You go in and you see
these little glasses and,
how could you leave without
buying a pair of glasses, right?
FRANK: Is this something
you would sell?
TERRY: I would,
if the price was right.
FRANK: Okay.
I think in a retail setting,
it'd be up to maybe 700.
I would be in it...
for $550.
TERRY: I think that's good.
Let me...
Jean?
JEAN: Yes.
You said how much, 550?
FRANK: 550.
JEAN: I think that's good.
FRANK: So 550 will do it?
TERRY: It's done.
FRANK: Alright.
Thank you.
TERRY: Done deal.
FRANK: Thank you very much.
FRANK: A lot of this stuff
Terry and Jean have bought
is great, highly
collectible stuff.
But they bought it
at the right time,
and now it's worth
a lot of cash.
MIKE: Jean and Terry
bought the best of the best.
And for them, it wasn't
just about the buying,
it was about the journey.
FRANK: Ooh, here we go.
MIKE: For them, it was about
travelling together and finding
these things directly
connected to their life.
FRANK: See you, Terry!
[honks horn]
FRANK: See you, Jean!
JEAN: Bye!